angels of Las Vegas don't know if you've
heard of them but they help families
dealing with terminal illness in more
ways than one this weekend you'll have
the opportunity to help them continue
their mission Candace Charles joins us
live from their location off West Sahara
and South Buffalo this morning with more
on their work and how we can all help
good morning Candace tell us more about
them
good morning Jay good morning folks I
know you guys can see the food in front
of me this is what you guys can enjoy At
the Gala including of course drinks and
just a chance to get to see the work the
angels of Las Vegas does you'll get to
speak with some of the patients that
they work with as well the tickets start
at a hundred dollars I'm joined by via
Brazil's Las Vegas who made all of this
great food Annie Gomez thank you so much
for joining me today tell us a little
bit about what's on the menu oh my
goodness so we're gonna have the
Brazilian meatballs 100 beef as well as
Caesar salad Brazilian chicken
stroganoff Brazilian rice and the new
item on the menu right now we have a
chicken sandwich okay so everybody's
going to enjoy the food please come
hungry okay don't eat come hungry come
ready and prepared to of course enjoy a
great evening get to see Anna there
she's worked with angels Las Vegas for
quite some time thank you Anna for
chatting with us and I'm joined by the
great mind behind it all Annie Gooden
thank you so much for joining us today
tell us a little bit about the work of
angels Las Vegas thank you so much for
being here today to Showcase everything
while we do and you know what with the
wigs and the nutrition the food that we
give away it's growing our organization
is getting so big right now and it's all
about the community supporting us like
via Brazil steakhouse has been with us
for almost 12 years now 13 years yes we
actually did our night of Hope at via
Brazil four years ago we started out
there now we're growing we did in the
candies Wilson house now we're doing our
first Gala nice and it's like huge event
I know you guys already have maybe a
hundred or more people that are planning
to come how do you guys hope that this
will help you continue to do what you
need to do and how much money are you
hoping to raise well last year we raised
28 000 28 000 meters our goal is 50 000
this year and it's gonna help us with
our goals our mission so we're going to
have auction item live action and and
also at live entertainment it's going to
be so much fun nice drinks and
everything so we want the community to
come out to enjoy you have a great food
meet our patient meet our supporters
it's going to be a fun night awesome
thank you so much thank you Anna for all
the work you guys do in the community
again the event is this Saturday the
gala is on December 10th this Saturday
starts at six o'clock of course we got
to cover with all details on our website
8newsnow.com now if you can't make it to
the gala you can still donate as well
we'll have a link to uh the Angels Las
Vegas website so you can donate there
for now live from the Angels Las Vegas
I'm Candace Charles 8 News Now